C'est bien connu, les pommes de
terre ont tendance à germer si
on les oublie trop longtemps. Et
dans les entrepôts, des maladies
les guettent également. Pour les
protéger, on utilise depuis des
années un pesticide controversé.
Mais il y a une lueur d'espoir
sous la forme d'une substance
issue de la forêt boréale.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narratrice): Fraîche,
en frites ou en croustilles,
la pomme de terre est populaire
au Canada. Nous en consommons
près de 58 kg chacun par année,
ce qui en fait notre légume
préféré -- oui, oui,
un légume --, loin devant
la tomate. En Europe aussi,
la pomme de terre a son public.
Mais depuis octobre 2020, la
Commission européenne interdit
l'utilisation du produit le plus
répandu dans le monde contre la
germination des pommes de terre
en entrepôt : le chlorprophame,
ou CIPC, à cause des risques
pour la santé.
- C'est surtout concernant
sa toxicité, autant dans
l'environnement que du côté
des consommateurs aussi;
parce que le CIPC, il va être
très persistant. C'est que,
au niveau de la transformation
alimentaire des pommes de terre,
on retrouve du CIPC ou de
ses métabolites de dégradation
dans l'huile de friture ou
encore même dans les frites.
- Mais Santé Canada en permet
toujours l'utilisation.
L'institution se base
sur son évaluation de 2008,
et la prochaine est prévue en
2023-2024. Aucune discussion
n'est en cours au MAPAQ.
Nous produisons au pays
près de 5 millions de tonnes
de pommes de terre chaque année.
Elles sont récoltées de juillet
à octobre, puis entreposées
pour être distribuées aux
consommateurs tout au long
de l'année.
- Avec un antigerminatif, avec
un contrôle de la température,
un contrôle de l'humidité,
on est capable de fournir
un 10 mois facilement
d'entreposage.
- Mais, chaque année, cet
entreposage cause la perte de
10 % de la récolte; une perte
chiffrée à 75 millions $.
Très efficace, le CIPC est aussi
le moins cher sur le marché.
- On s'y attend à ce que ce soit
interdit ici par nos propres
gouvernements. Ou encore,
ça pourrait être un joueur
majeur qui interdirait, lui,
d'acheter des pommes de terre
qui contiennent du CIPC.
- Pendant ce temps,
les producteurs de pommes de
terre prennent les devants.
Ils ont contacté des
scientifiques pour trouver
un nouvel antigerminatif.
Tout commence en 2018, dans les
laboratoires de l'Université du
Québec à Trois-Rivières et ceux
d'Innofibre. Michelle Boivin
est alors étudiante chercheuse
associée à ce projet.
- Notre idée, c'est d'utiliser
les écorces, toujours en ayant
un procédé plus écologique
de fabrication qui, en bout
de ligne, aura aussi un impact
moindre sur la santé des
consommateurs, mais aussi
sur la santé des producteurs
de pommes de terre.
- Comme les écorces d'arbres
ont aussi des propriétés
antimicrobiennes, les
chercheuses pensent qu'elles
pourraient régler un deuxième
problème dans les entrepôts,
celui du développement des
maladies dans les pommes de
terre.
- Donc nous, avec nos écorces,
on a voulu vraiment étudier
s'il n'y avait pas un potentiel
antimicrobien et antigerminatif.
- Elle récupère des écorces,
des branches et des aiguilles
dans les résidus de la
cogénération de Saint-Félicien,
au Lac-Saint-Jean, avant qu'ils
soient brûlés comme source
d'énergie.
- On a travaillé avec le bouleau
jaune, l'épinette noire, puis
aussi le sapin baumier, qu'on a
fait plusieurs tests. Puis en
bout de ligne, c'est vraiment
l'épinette noire qui en ressort
le grand gagnant. On a fait
des tests antigerminatifs.
On a appliqué directement nos
extraits de toutes les sortes
d'arbres sur la surface de nos
pommes de terre. Après un mois
seulement, on pouvait déjà aller
voir les patates qu'on avait
traitées, s'il y avait eu des
germes... ce qu'on veut pas!
- Elle suit les mêmes étapes
pour trouver un antimicrobien
efficace, après avoir inoculé
des maladies. Après des mois
de recherches, les résultats
en laboratoire sont concluants.
Il faut maintenant passer
à l'échelle des tests en
entrepôts, qui nécessitent de
grandes quantités d'extraits
d'épinette noire. Disponible
sous forme d'huile essentielle
pour l'action antigerminative,
il faut par contre fabriquer
l'antimicrobien.
La chimiste Nathalie Bourdeau
prend le relais.
- Le défi dans ce projet,
c'est vraiment d'arriver à
isoler les molécules actives
dans notre ingrédient. C'est en
fait des molécules qu'on vient
sortir des écorces. Et il faut
arriver à optimiser le procédé
pour qu'il soit, à l'échelle
industrielle, le plus économique
possible pour que ce soit
viable. On est très excités
par la journée d'aujourd'hui.
On est contents. Tout se passe
bien. Donc, on a pris les
écorces, qu'on a mises dans
le réacteur avec une certaine
quantité d'eau. Et sous l'effet
de la chaleur, l'eau va aller
chercher les molécules d'intérêt
dans les écorces. Et on ramène
à sec les molécules qui se
trouvent dans le liquide.
Ça va se retrouver sous forme
de poudre, qui va être formulée
pour pouvoir être appliquée
sur les pommes de terre à
l'entreposage.
- Nathalie Bourdeau et Michelle
Boivin rejoignent Sophie Massie
dans les entrepôts de recherche
à Sainte-Croix-de-Lotbinière
pour la prochaine étape des
tests à l'échelle industrielle.
- On a mis en place un
traitement avec des huiles
essentielles en provenance
d'épinettes noires.
Et on va avoir un contrôle avec
le CIPC pour venir comparer
les résultats au courant
de la saison d'entreposage.
- Les tubercules circulent sur
un convoyeur pour être traités
par pulvérisation des différents
extraits.
- Pour le volet antimicrobien,
nous avons testé trois
pathogènes, des pathogènes
qu'on retrouve couramment dans
les entrepôts du Québec :
pourriture molle créée par
les bactéries, Pectobacterium,
Dickeya,  puis aussi pourriture
sèche engendrée par le Fusarium.
Et un peu comme pour le volet
antigerminatif, on va tester
les huiles et les extraits.
- Quelques mois plus tard, la
chercheuse analyse les effets
des traitements sur les milliers
de pommes de terre entreposées.
- L'évaluation hebdomadaire
qu'on fait pour évaluer la
germination des tubercules
consiste à évaluer s'il y a
des germes de moins de 2 mm.
Sinon, après ça, c'est de
compter combien il y a de germes
de plus de 2 mm. Et ensuite,
on mesure le germe le plus long.
Ça, c'est les pommes de terre
témoins, contrôles. En fait,
elles ont reçu aucun extrait.
La germination est passablement
avancée sur cette variété-là.
Ce qu'on va voir tantôt avec
l'antigerminatif, c'est voir
si c'est moins avancé que ça.
- Les pommes de terre traitées
au CIPC ne présentent presque
aucun germe.
- Donc pour l'extrait 3,
AC Chaleur 3.
- Sophie et son équipe arrivent
maintenant à la boîte qui
contient les pommes de terre
traitées avec l'huile
essentielle d'épinette noire.
- On voit très bien que le
produit a brûlé les germes.
Donc, aucun germe de plus
de 2 mm et aucun germe
de moins de 2 mm.
Pour l'antigerminatif, les
résultats sont comparables
au CIPC. Donc on a pu observer
une efficacité aux alentours
de 94-95 % du contrôle de
la germination.
- Pour les tests antimicrobiens,
elles cherchent le développement
de pourriture molle ou de
pourriture sèche.
- On a une pourriture molle,
deux pourritures molles...
On a de très bons résultats
comparativement aux contrôles
où la majorité des tubercules
étaient malades. Ici, on peut
voir : il y a seulement
2 tubercules sur les 25 qui sont
affectés. L'extrait d'épinette
noire est efficace pour
certaines maladies, notamment
la pourriture molle causée
par la bactérie.Pectobacterium.
On parle d'une efficacité
d'environ 90 %. Il faut savoir
qu'au Québec, il y a très, très
peu de produits homologués pour
contrôler la pourriture molle
post-récolte, donc en entrepôt.
Donc, c'est une très bonne
nouvelle qu'on ait un produit
prometteur pour ce genre de
maladies.
- On est bien contents des
résultats qu'on a obtenus
jusqu'à maintenant, tant
au niveau de l'ingrédient
antigerminatif que de
l'ingrédient antimicrobien.
Maintenant, avant de se rendre
au niveau commercial, il reste
quand même plusieurs étapes
à réaliser, que ce soit, d'un
côté, démontrer l'innocuité de
ces produits-là, parce que ça va
être appliqué sur des aliments.
D'un autre, c'est de démontrer
que ça n'affecte pas la qualité
de la pomme de terre, que ce
soit au niveau du goût, de
la couleur. Parce que ça peut
avoir un impact quand on les
transforme, par exemple comme
en croustilles. Alors ça,
c'est toutes des choses
qui vont rester à étudier.
- Ces études vont durer
plusieurs années avant
l'homologation du produit.
Si tous les critères sont
remplis, il pourrait être
fabriqué dans une nouvelle
usine à Saint-Félicien.
- On est très optimistes que
notre produit québécois se
retrouve chez les producteurs
de pommes de terre, autant au
Québec qu'ailleurs au Canada.
♪ ♪ ♪